nouveau numéro de reporter sur france 24
on cite souvent en exemple le système de
santé français permettant à tous un
accès à une médecine de qualité mais le
propos méritent d'être nuancés car les
disparités sont nombreuses et selon que
vous habitez en ville en banlieue ou à
la campagne vous risquez parfois
d'attendre bien longtemps avant de
décrocher un rendez vous médical chez un
spécialiste de tam ans on appelle ça les
déserts médicaux des zones où il n'y a
pas assez de médecins en proportion de
la population le gouvernement a décidé
d'augmenter le nombre d'étudiants admis
en deuxième année mais ça va prendre des
années avant que les médecins soient
formés pour certains il faudrait inciter
plus fortement les jeunes à s'installer
dans les territoires tour de france de
ses déserts médicaux avec claire pas
qu'alain et pauline godard de france 24
[Musique]
cabinet médical henri dunant moi j'en
madame oui et déjà pas duchesneau
aujourd'hui non c'est pas possible non
j'ai plus de place du tout madame à
madame pour votre douleur il est surtout
à gauche là dans la bouche
elle a des goûts
très bien double up rapide' demain avec
monsieur voulait se trouve depuis ce
matin j'ai raté 52 appels téléphoniques
ça peut être des personnes qui appellent
plusieurs fois mais c'est quand même
très frustrante se dire que il ya des
personnes qui n'arrivent pas à nous
joindre mais on est au maximum de peut
donner
voici le docteur héros il fait partie
des douze médecins généralistes
retraités qui exercent dans ce centre de
santé la pénurie de praticiens était
telle dans la ville de laval qu'ils ont
décidé de reprendre du service chacun
travaille un jour par semaine
ça
analyse d'urines elle était presque
c'est moi qui l'avais presque
continue à travailler un peu de travail
à un peu parce que je sais pas comment
les gens ils frère
comme c'est ce que j'avais dit à la
pharmacie comme il faut mais ce débat si
j'ai plus rien comment je fais j'arrête
tout les trucs moches et où
nous sommes dans le département de la
mayenne troisième désert médical de
france
ici il y à 65 médecin généraliste pour
100000 habitants contre 89 en moyenne
dans l'hexagone
les médecins se trouve plutôt dans le
sud où la densité peut atteindre 125
pour cent mille habitants trouver des
médecins ici c'est la vraie galère ouais
j'ai fait tous les médecins que j'ai pu
loiron saint berthevin changé laval
impossible vous vous habitez ou alors en
vrille et
18 km le dr héros a tout de suite adhéré
à ce projet mais projet élaboré en
partenariat avec notamment la mairie de
laval et le conseil départemental de la
mayenne à 71 ans il évoque les raisons
pour lesquelles il a dirigé le bulbe
landes c'est le fait de se dire ben on
est encore capable de faire quelque
chose on a on a on a un métier qu'on a
aimé et que ça fait plaisir de continuer
à le faire je dis toujours on est un peu
des drogues et de la médecine et puis la
deuxième raison ce service
aujourd'hui 4400 patients ont un médecin
traitant grâce à eux mais ce qui devait
être provisoire est en train de
s'installer dans la durée bientôt cinq
ans que le centre de santé existent de
médecins retraités et un interne
consultent chaque jour
donc d'une apathie maternelle celle
interne du docteur héros que juste à
côté je vais commencer la consultation
il engendre à la fin ce qui nous amène à
la de la fia c'est ça oui
gaël est soulagé d'avoir trouvé ce
rendez-vous pour sa fille cela fait six
mois qu'elle s'est installée à laval et
elle n'a toujours pas réussi à trouver
de médecin traitant j'ai dû appeler la
première fois une quinzaine de cabinets
c'est clairement une problématique où on
dit quand même sur une grande ville
comme laval on devrait trouver un
médecin puisque c'est pas une toute
petite ville est en fête non c'est vrai
problème
pour moi c'était on en parle à la télé
pour moi c'était
pensais pas que ça pouvait nous arriver
de ne pas trouver des médecins quand
des médecins retraités pour qui il est
essentiel de former la jeune génération
alors c'est pour clara qui est gênant
pour de la chaire de pierre elle a vomi
que sur les pics de pierre sinon on
faisait ce qu'elle aime à sur les côtés
hier pas plus mal aujourd'hui
contact avec les jeunes ça nous permet
en effet d'assurer la suite de
les acides la médecine générale et puis
ben euh il apporte un petit peu les
choses nouvelles une nouvelle
recommandation parfait de nouveaux
traitements on leur apporte notre
expérience
alors
trouver un médecin généraliste eux reste
un casse-tête pour bon nombre de
communes ici dans l'est de la france
dans le département de l'aude ils sont
69 pour cent mille habitants nogent sur
seine en compte quatre dont un qui s'est
installé récemment mais on est encore
loin du compte
c'est pourquoi la ville a décidé
d'ouvrir il ya trois ans une salle de
téléconsultation peintures montrent là
où
le patient est prise en charge par
marion l'infirmière elle s'occupe du
prêt examen elle assiste ensuite le
médecin qui lui se trouve dans une autre
vie du département un petit peu oui mais
passons sont rassurés parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui me disent mais comment je
vais faire pour que le médecin et
puissante en mon coeur qu'ils puissent
entendre les poumons et je sens vraiment
qu'ils sont rassurés que je sois là
parce que je peux les guider et puis et
puis je suis un petit peu je gêne le
médecin mon cul
aussi c'est parfait donc il est à
construire au début j'avais pas trop
confiance parce que je pensais pas que
tout était connecté je pensais que voilà
on me disait ce que l'enfant avait avec
eux on se fie à juste aux symptômes sont
voir vraiment et la voilà en revoyant la
gorge tout est connecté donc c'est quand
même chloration en solutions de secours
c'est super bon après je préfère voir le
médecin traitant s'assure mais voilà la
petite il fallait des médicaments
entrepris donc c'est top
de l'autre côté de l'écran les docteurs
de villaret goodur ancien urgentiste à
l'hôpital public de 3 ils sont partis
d'un constat de plus en plus de
personnes venaient aux urgences faute
d'avoir un médecin banques afin de les
désengorger ils ont créé ce cabinet de
télémédecine le seul en france reconnu
par l'ordre des médecins
on a des remerciements régulier
mais aussi on a deux
cette amertume des patients aussi de
devoir être soigné comme sa distance par
un médecin parce qu'il préférait
forcément savoir un médecin physique et
on en fait bien entendre qu'on est là de
façon provisoire le temps qui a trouvé
un médecin traitant et l'otan qui
quelqu'un sont intéressés pour revient
sur le territoire un partenariat renfort
qui peut qui peut les assistés en fait
c'étaient les consultations ont une
spécificité elles ont lieu exclusivement
dans la région grand est dont 70 salles
dédiées on va construire avec un
généraliste avec le cabinet d'infirmiers
avec le pharmacien avec les kinés avec
vraiment tout ce petit écosystème du
territoire du village à l'échelle de la
commune généralement ou de la communauté
de communes si c'est assez réduite on va
construire un vrai projet médical qu'on
va écrire ensemble et puis dans lequel
vont être décrit tous les process accès
à cette télé consultation la prise de
rendez-vous les heures d'ouverture qui
va assister le patient
les déserts médicaux ne touche pas que
les zones rurales aux portes de paris en
seine-saint-denis trouver un médecin est
quasi mission impossible
ici la densité de médecins généralistes
et de 59 pour cent mille habitants
l'un des pires chiffres du pays à livry
gargan ces deux dernières années six
départs à la retraite n'ont pas été
remplacés
comment allez vous madame dauvillaire
ce sera bientôt au tour du dr welland de
passer la main déjà plusieurs années
qu'il repousse son départ à la retraite
mais cette fois c'est décidé il
raccrochera le stéthoscope le 30 juin
2022 dont il aura passé 43 ans a soigné
les lives rien ça va ça vous plaît
il faut bien ainsi qu'il
est ce qu'il va y avoir quelqu'un
d'autre bon on l'essaie on essaye de
trouver
est ce que ça vous inquiète mme adame ba
oui un peu parce que maintenant il ya
beaucoup de docteurs qui veulent plus
venir à domicile et comme moi j'ai
craint des difficultés à marcher
quand vous avez un docteur qui vient de
me chercher quand même des pratiques
pour vous quoi
c'est parce que c'est de vieillir
on voudrait john madame louis
viderait bien voilà ses 92 ans cette
année mais c'est ça
oui
le problème ne va pas se changer en si
peu de temps on sait très bien que avec
l'histoire du numerus clausus qui a été
faible ya de nombreuses années on n'a
pas à recruter suffisamment de médecins
pendant plus de 40 ans le numerus
clausus à limiter le nombre d'étudiants
admis en deuxième année de médecine en
parallèle la population française a
continué de croître tout comme la
demande de soins et donc de besoins en
médecins ce parti ces dernières années à
la retraite n'ont été que peu remplacés
on s'était battu à l'époque pour me dire
que c'était une bêtise de cette histoire
de numerus clausus qui avait été
inventée simplement par des technocrates
dans ce cas là en disant il ya trop de
consommation médicale on va supprimer
les médecins donc on va supprimer la
maladie quasiment quoi alors quand on
s'est rendu compte que c'est pas du tout
ça
depuis 2021 fini le numerus clausus pour
la première fois l'année dernière un
nombre record d'étudiants est passé en
deuxième année ce qui commence à poser
problème aux facultés quoi qu'il en soit
il faudra être patient avant d'en voir
les bénéfices il faut neuf ans pour
former un médecin généraliste
médecin qui s'établissent à 20 ans
désert médical
suivre
pourquoi
les gens venise docteur vous êtes encore
au travail ça fait déjà trois fois que
vous dites-vous parti à la retraite et
je repousse voyez ce que je veux dire
donc c'est que ma meilleure façon de ne
pas angoisser c'est de continuer à
travailler mais un jour faudra quand
même 74 ans faudra quand même que je que
je passe
l'ama aux autres
donc là vous êtes en recherche active
recherche active on est en face ça ne
donne rien ce soit sur la commune c'est
un fructueux allez donc je vous dis à
bientôt monsieur à la prochaine et vous
m'appelez quand vous voulez hein en dix
ans la seine saint denis a perdu près de
25% de médecins généralistes
enfin moi je l'imaginé en tant que
médecin généraliste vue là les
problématiques de démographie médicale
en fait coco faut que tu t'installes
dans une zone où il ya besoin de toi
mais du coup ça prenait l'ascenseur des
trappes en temps et puis après bluetooth
et embarqués on sait marquer la
contrainte il y a un an la maison de
santé au fil de l'eau est sorti de terre
un projet porté par paul et ilham et
l'oci jeunes médecins généralistes
ne pas travailler seul pouvoir échanger
avec d'autres collègues sont très d
avoir une offre complémentaire de soi
telle était leur souhait
ici quatre médecins généralistes
travaillent à plein temps des
orthophonistes une sage femme un
psychiatre et un psychologue
ça donne vraiment l'impression d'être à
la maison personnellement j'ai
s'y sent bien il fait d'être réussie
avec des médecins j'aime préval écoute
davantage la maison santé c'est que
j'appelle imaginons mois mais quatre ou
cinq plages de rendez vous d'urgence ont
sont prises je peux peut-être quand même
on est quatre médecins ici levy
remplaçant et c'est peu dire maintien
est ce que tu viens tu le pouvoir à
lachen n'est pas bien je suis je suis je
suis demandé aujourd'hui
c'est du boulot on a refait tout ça mais
intense des barons et chimie mais bien
ça fait petite maison
médicale mais familial quoi mais il a
fallu s'accrocher pour pouvoir
concrétiser son projet son coût peut
donner le tournis plus d'un million
trois cent mille euros les deux médecins
ont pu bénéficier d'environ 500 mille
euros d aides de la région et de la
mairie et d'un accompagnement précieux
celui de l'ue rps l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé
l'acompte sur lesquels vous avez jamais
été formés à la faculté on dire que fort
logiquement vous apprendre la médecine
ont joué bien moi je suis un peu on
jamais l'aspect architectural aspects
financiers juridiques à monter les
dossiers tout l'administratif un médecin
dans un territoire c'est un ciment
sociétal il va attirer il va attirer les
pharmacies va caresser les soignants il
va attirer de la population des
commerces etc donc il faut encourager
nous on tient à ce que vous trouviez
votre
bonheur d'installation en restant dans
la région
depuis 2018 lui rps à accompagner 29
projets similaires en seine saint denis
mais comme dans beaucoup de villes ces
maisons de santé sont rapidement
victimes de leur succès là ça fait un an
qu'on a ouvert et moi en tous cas pour
ma part je me pose déjà la question de
commencer à l'imiter
les nouveaux parce que ce qu'on a
accepté me disent déjà bas pour les
rendez-vous ça devient les délais
commencent à devenir longue mais c'est
de réfléchir un peu comme on peut
s'organiser pour
augmentation du nombre d'assistants
médicaux hausse dz contrainte à
l'installation pour les médecins les
propositions des candidats à la
présidentielle sont nombreuses pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux
le prochain président trouvera-t-il la
solution à ce mal qui ronge la france ce
sera en tout cas l'un de ses principaux
défis
[Musique]
voilà pour ce tour de france des déserts
médicaux et cet enjeu de la prochaine
présidentielle reportage signé clair pas
qu'alain et pauline godard c'est la fin
de ce magazine on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur france 24
[Musique]